c'est une affaire qui a beaucoup choqué
celle de ce livreur appuyé à
l'application des livres ou qui a refusé
de livrer plusieurs restaurants casher
de strasbourg parce qu'ils étaient
spécialisés dans la cuisine israélienne
à plusieurs reprises ce livre
ouvertement antisémite a expliqué aux
restaurateurs concernés qui ne servaient
pas les juifs depuis plusieurs plaintes
ont été déposées et le parquet de
strasbourg compte bien faire la lumière
sur cette terrible histoire
hier soir l'un des restaurateurs
concernés par ces attaques étaient sur
notre plateau pour nous faire part de
son émotion
10 e j cachez pas pour les juifs il est
parti si je savais jamais arrivé donc
j'étais sous le choc
si des livres a très rapidement fait
savoir qu'elle avait l'intention
d'enquêter pour comprendre ce qui
s'était passé
une plainte a été déposée contre
l'entreprise britannique un représentant
de des livres ou et sur notre plateau ce
soir pour tout nous dire sur cette
affaire et sur ce que compte faire la
compagnie
[Musique]
alors qu'ils vont arriver dans un
instant je sais qu'il y en a qui voulait
réagir encore sur cette affaire qui a
fait énormément parler j'ai eu
énormément de remerciement de la part
des internautes donc merci à vous
d'avoir mis cette affaire en lumière ou
vont arriver dans un instant vous le
savez on est en direct
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire oui non
s'est jamais posé la question et je
souhaite maintenant leur poser de vive
voix c'était que les ont ils n'arrivent
pas à trouver les mis en cause et je
voulais savoir pourquoi puisque nous on
arrive à le savoir sur l'application à
savoir les prénoms des livreurs donc
pourquoi eux n'arrivaient pas à remonter
jusqu'à leurs traces alors que
normalement ils sont géolocalisées
sûrement l'usurpateur oui la vraie
question c'est est-ce que cet incident
ils auraient pu être évités dans une
entreprise classique vous avez vous fait
des entretiens d'embauché vous
rencontrer les salariés vous intéresser
à leur vie si je tombais sur un dégénéré
un fou vous pouvez vous en rendre un pas
tout le temps attendez là des livres ou
c'est un système on en parlera avec
monsieur il ya 14000 livreur en france
c'est des auto-entrepreneurs on ne sait
pas des salariés des libéraux donc
malheureusement c'est un peu et c'est
pas de la faute de l'entreprise mais
c'est un peu les limites de ce système
c'est qu'on sait pas qui on a affaire
moi si j'ai un pote qui est des livres
ou qui me prête sont son sac et sa combi
je peux devenir livres des livres ou et
m'appeler robert gilbert pour l'import
et et me faire passer pour quelqu'un de
donc c'est un peu les limites du système
et c'est ce que je voulais demander à
monsieur alors à ben justement ils sont
allés ne pas contrer par rentrer le
représentant des libéraux est l'avocat
des restaurateurs merci d'être là aussi
installé vous remercie d'avoir vraiment
réagi aussi vite à cette affaire damien
ce qu'il faut vous êtes porte-parole de
délivrons ça va vous arriver à vous
asseoir tout va bien mais bien en tout
cas je dois vous dire bravo en tout cas
d'avoir réagi aussi vite dès l'hiver où
je trouve que vraiment c'était forme
votre part et c'est vrai que ce qui
s'est passé
merci d'être avec nous également je vous
ai vu hier ont fait steyn vous êtes
encore plus beau en vrai et c'est vrai
que ce qui s'est passé ça ça a choqué
tout le monde et le fait que vous
réagissiez directement il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont dit ah c'est bien que des
livres ou voile a réagi ce conte comment
comment ça s'est passé comment ça peut
se passer ça merci de votre habitation
syrie d'abord et c'est bien normal que
qu'on ait réagi et comme ce soit rendue
disponible parce que on était aussi
choqués que vous tous sur le plateau je
comprends très bien votre émotion on la
partage je n'ai eu de cesse depuis hier
en fait de dire que cet acte la noë
volts antisémitisme racisme la
discrimination de toute nature c'est des
choses qui sera absolument inqualifiable
et qui ne correspondent pas du tout aux
valeurs que nous nous privons chez de la
marque voilà vraiment prône des libéraux
avec qui il n'y a jamais eu vraiment
c'est de souci est ce que vous pouvez
retrouver les la personne qui a qui a
qui a fait ça oui absolument on a bon
espoir de retrouver la personne qui a
fait ça et ça devrait pas poser de
problème aujourd'hui là on est en
discussions étroites avec les services
de police
d'accord qui se sont emparés du sujet et
qui enquêtent on s'est mis à leur
disposition intégral naturellement et on
va les aider à retrouver l'auteur de ces
faits alors merci d'être là maître
raphaël nisand
je sais que le restaurateur est
extrêmement choqués on l'a vu hier
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire au porte
parole des libéraux aujourd'hui
alors c'est bien que des libéraux
réagissent nantiat bravo à vous la
longueur ça c'est super mais jeudi soir
quand les camps l'incident s'est passé
il n'y a pas eu de réaction ou pas une
réaction satisfaisante
quand le restaurateur s'est adressé à
des livres où on lui a répondu après non
on lui a dit à bas le lol le livreur il
s'appelle un tel jésus bon ça semble
être un nom d'emprunt ou un alias
franchement et puis on lui a dit on va
prévenir son supérieur hiérarchique
alors qu'à pas de supérieur hiérarchique
et puis plus de nouvelles après donc il
nous a semblé que puis les restaurateurs
étaient très choqués par cette réponse
et par l'absence totale de réactivité
on est jeudi soir jeudi soir des livres
ou aux abonnés absents et il a fallu la
plainte des restaurateurs n'a pas suffi
parce qu'elle n'était pas contre des
livres où il a fallu la plainte du bnvca
debout sur gauclin et du consistoire
israélite du bas-rhin le dimanche tels
que j'ai déposé le dimanche contre dès
l'hiver ou aussi pour que dès l'hiver où
se bouge à partir de lundi matin quelque
chose à répondre à ça alors je
n'enchaîne mans des faits n'est pas tout
à fait celui ci mais je ne veux pas
aller sur ce terrain là ce que je peux
vous garantir c'est que les faire les
prend très au sérieux
s'il ya eu un petit retard à l'allumage
je le regrette je le déplore mais c'est
typiquement pas le genre de chose sur
lequel on est laxiste ou qu'on va
laisser passer pour nous c'est quelque
chose ont réagi
tan tan et man on veut condamner
fermement des agissements comme ça ils
sont inacceptables absolument pas
conforme à nos valeurs
j'ai parlé à ses deux restaurateurs hier
matin dans une conversation très
constructive je les ai assuré du soutien
de delivery et de notre aide
évidemment pour faire émerger la vérité
là dessus qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui va
se passer alors maintenant vous allez
essayer de retrouver
voilà les la personne qui a fait ça elle
va être sanctionné bien entendu oui
alors naturellement donc je suis certain
que les services de police vont faire
leur enquête et que la meilleure
diligence possible et nous on dressera
on sera à leur disposition les moyens
dont nous on disposera et l'engagement
qu'on peut prendre aujourd'hui c'est que
si l'auteur des faits est retrouvé et il
ne sera ici les faits sont qualifiés et
je n'ai aucun doute qu'ils ne seront
s'ils sont avérés nous on agira on
mettra un terme à d'autres coopérations
commerciales avec ce prestataire là
d'accord parce que on veut faire je ne
dirais pas qu'on veut faire un exemple
mais on veut qu'il soit très fermement
entendu que pour nous ce genre
d'agissements sont une exception
bien sûr oui nicolas pernikoff et j'ai
une question un moment donné vous les
rémunérer ces gens n'y a pas de pillages
à la question mais vous savez pas qui
sait où voulait pas donner son nom
alors bien sûr que nous savons qu'ils se
sont qui ils sont
moi je naturellement je ne donnerai pas
oui bien sûr je vais en fait sur le nord
pas de calais je vous demande oui il
faut pas ajouter la vindicte l outrage
bien sûr et c'est une ambiance alourdie
sur le fait que vous savez vous l'avez
oui naturellement après il ya des choses
il faut démêler l'écheveau quoi si vous
voulez donc l'émotion de tout le monde
elle est légitime et on la partage on
veut faire les choses en lien avec la
police en lien avec vous m 10 ans de
manière extrêmement méthodique pour que
voilà à la fin les choses soient soit
clair qu'il soit dit et qu'on puisse
agir un merci en tout cas des livres
métro 10 ans que la réponse de des
rivaux vous convient c'est une partie de
satisfaction parce que encore une fois
il y a eu réaction depuis hier voilà et
cette réaction
c'est vrai qu'elle est bien je suis un
peu surpris quand même que la police
n'ait pas encore mis la main sur
l'individu parce qu'il avait une
tablette dès l'hiver où il est vraiment
pis table de façon électronique et donc
c'est une personne
les restaurateurs m'aurait dit s'ils
avaient été confrontés avec lui pour à
sept minutes et bien la coopération des
verrous n'a pas été jusqu'à son terme
puisque a pas eu d'interpellation